hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 15 video nanda
parbat this was basically like the
culmination of a big storyline called
the daughter of the demon the Batman
comics so I'll explain what that is and
then I'll get into my top five moments
so just careful for spoilers from the
comics and from this episode if you
haven't seen it yet arrow this season
has been adapting one of the best Batman
stories of all time or at least Batman
stories that don't take place inside
Gotham if you're gonna tell a racial
goals story you might as well tell one
of the best ones of all time
arrow has its own really big cast of
characters that have they're running
storylines that don't necessarily fit
with what was going on in this Batman
comic but I think the producers did a
really good job of adapting it in the
comic book Batman finds out that Robin
has been kidnapped
Rachele Ghul appears out of nowhere
introduces himself and says that they
have the same problem my daughter Talia
was also kidnapped so they go on a
mission to rescue them Rochelle Goyle
blames the kidnapping on a cult called
the Brotherhood of the demon obviously a
nice twist on the League of Assassins
Rachele ghoul being the demons head they
go all over the world trying to track
them down and end up climbing this
really famous mountain which actually I
think from the mid-season finale is
meant to signify in the comics the
mountain was called Nanda Devi I don't
think on the show they ever announced
what the name of that mountain was that
they fought on top of so once Rachel
ghoul and Batman get to the top of the
mountain Batman realizes that the whole
thing was a hoax perpetrated by ratio
goal to try and pick a successor it was
basically him trying to vet Batman as
his successor and League of Assassins to
become the next Ra's al Ghul they also
did this storyline you might have seen
out in the animated series it was called
daemons quest I think it was a two-part
episode so if you're a big fan of the
animated series and you don't like to
read a whole lot just watch that it's
the same story so you can see there are
a lot of elements that are different its
Nyssa al Ghul instead of Talia she's not
in love with Oliver Queen but you get
the idea so the interesting thing is is
I think they're gonna blend some
elements of the Nyssa character into
this and use it as a way to propel the
back half of the season I have all kinds
of thoughts about where they're gonna
take the rest of the season based on
what just happened so I'll try to
explain that as we get through top five
moments so here we go top five moments
number five raesha al Ghul opens the
episode in the Lazarus Pit for those
that are wondering this is their lazarus
pit set this hot tub that he's in
several weeks ago one
writers in the show said that they have
a Lazarus Pit set and that when they're
on it they make a lot of Hot Tub Time
Machine jokes so anytime you see this
hot tub that's at BAM lazarus pit I know
it doesn't have green flowing liquid or
anything like that but racial ghouls
specifically says that he met a magician
in 1854 doing the math look at him right
here you can guess the Lazarus Pit does
work and if you did see the animated
series I'm actually I'm gonna spoil that
real quick so I'll put the spoiler tag
up here what ends up happening in that
Batman storyline because I think they're
gonna do the same thing on arrow okay so
here we go in the animated series Batman
turns down racial goal he says I don't
want to take over the League of
Assassins and racial Ghul ends up
landing in the Lazarus Pit and in
business goes on as usual so that means
that racial Ghul could be resurrected at
the end of this season if anyone's gonna
get to use the Lazarus Pit this year
it's gonna be racial goal
no one's gonna use it before he does
okay so spoilers over I just say that
because everyone's wondering you know
are they gonna use the Lazarus Pit is
anyone gonna be brought back to life so
based on what I just said that's what I
think is gonna happen I'll explain the
why as we go along because there's a lot
of stuff that could happen between now
and the end of the season moving on to
number four
Roy tries to help Thea stop from
flipping out as expected as Oliver said
Thea is starting to feel the guilt of
sending her father to his death as bad
as Malcolm Merlyn is Oliver was totally
right she's gonna end up regretting it
for the rest of her life she cannot look
Laurel in the face and probably whenever
Quentin comes back she's not gonna be
able to be around him either Roy took
her to the family of the cop that he
killed and just let her know that yeah I
do nice things for them they don't know
about it it helps me feel better about
what I did so yes I think we all expect
her to adjust at a certain point like
they'll all return to baseline by the
end of the season but it's gonna take a
little while moving out to number three
Nyssa vs. Merlyn this is probably one of
the best fight scenes in the episode
just because they're so good I love the
way Merlyn totally takes out Black
Canary - Oliver said it did you really
think that you had a chance against
Merlyn I feel like Oliver actually he
has really good advice for all the
people in this episode but because of
what he's doing because of the decisions
he's made everybody hates them so no
one's gonna do what Oliver says even if
it's totally the right thing one don't
challenge Malcolm Merlyn in open combat
- don't tell Laurel what happened
regardless of what you think of the
Laurel character I totally loved her
reaction to that she was like yeah I
remember what you said but then I
realized I don't give a
whenever they captured her whenever they
captured Nyssa did you see the steam
vents in the background I feel like
those were working overtime like they
they just wanted to set an atmosphere
like I've never seen those steam in the
air okay before but apparently capturing
the daughter of the demon merits a lot
of steam or maybe the arrow cave is
partially steam powered speaking of said
design on to number two Oliver and
Diggle infiltrate the League of
Assassins this is a really cool big
action set piece air arrow doesn't do
them a whole lot but every once in a
while like when they have a big episode
they do a really good job of doing this
big action crowd scenes
I know arrow has a really small set
budget but all these hallway shots
inside the league look amazing all these
lamps great set design I kind of want
some of these lamps from my apartment
they just look badass so I'm just gonna
save my number one obviously a tie
between Oliver being offered the League
of Assassins and Ray Palmer using his
atom suit so I'll just I'll just do one
write it together so we'll start with
the Oliver stuff both really big WTF
moments but let's talk about the really
important one first Oliver Queen needs
to become the next racial goal clearly
he's gonna find some way around it
there's no way Oliver Queen is gonna
stop being the arrow but for the rest of
this season I think that they're gonna
leave that hanging in the air I'm not
expecting him to outright say no I think
he's gonna entertain the idea for a
little while like let me think about it
I think he'll use the time deciding
whether or not to accept the offer to
save Merlyn but I'm imagining that he'll
probably end up in a fight with Rachel
Ghul to feed him this time and then
Rachel Ghul will end up in the Lazarus
Pit being resurrected for a potential
return in a future season I'd say the
biggest question mark now about what's
going on with Oliver in the League of
Assassins is what Nyssa is gonna do
about it if you guys have read any of
nYSSA's stories in the comics she
actually kind of comes off a little
crazy so what I think is gonna happen is
there'll be some sort of League Civil
War going on because she probably has
people loyal to her inside she wants to
be races air so obviously that conflict
has to be settled in blood this is
really important though I think we're
gonna end the season with Nyssa and
Rachel ghouls still alive and Merlyn I
don't think anyone's gonna die arrow
does a good job of keeping the really
big characters around they'll find a
creative way around it - I mean it's not
like they're just gonna walk away
scot-free
somebody's gonna end up in the Lazarus
Pit mark my words the producers said
that they have not decided whether Talia
exists in the aro universe yet they're
really undecided she could come in but
if she
she'll be second to Nyssa so that just
implies that they plan on keeping this
around for a long time so whatever and
this ends up doing this season she's not
gonna die okay so on to Adams stuff
clearly biggest thing the suit flies now
instead of shrinking that doesn't mean
that it won't shrink in the future and
there is gonna be an episode 18
crossover on the flash the flash episode
18 it's called all-star team up he's
gonna get some special tech some
additions to the suit no idea what it is
but in that storyline the villain is
actually gonna be Emily Kinney from The
Walking Dead she's gonna be playing
someone who makes a lot of miniature
bees so Adam miniature bees do the math
there might be some shrinkage going on
in that episode but I think for now his
powers will be a lot more practical
he'll be able to fly and he'll have
super-strength
given to him by the suit I was actually
way more surprised by the Adam stuff
than I was by the racial ghouls stuff
just because I haven't read a lot of
Adam comics it's always hard to tell
which direction arrows gonna take things
because more than any of the other DC
comic book shows they adapt stuff so
they'll change names they'll give
storylines to their characters so it's
really hard to tell what they're doing
from the comics just because they change
so much stuff I know a lot of you will
probably be asking about like the the
Felicity Ray Palmer sex scene stuff I
feel like but based on the way the
producers talk about it he's gonna push
her away so it's not like they're gonna
be having sex all the time she'll
probably end up having the same kind of
relationship with him that she had with
Oliver even though they consummated it
and she never actually had sex with
Oliver the way Stephen Amell explains it
in real life is that Felicity for Oliver
is this unattainable ideal like
something he's never gonna get to it
works better when they're not together
than when they are together so don't
expect her and Ray Palmer to be
buddy-buddy for too long probably a
couple more episodes but by the end of
the season
I'd expect Ray Palmer to move on to
something else that actually brings up
the point of the the Adam spin-off that
they're working off the atom TV show if
that ends up happening Ray Palmer will
just go on that and his character will
get his own show if it doesn't he'll
probably just bounce back and forth
between the flash and arrow that was
kind of the plan for the Barry Allen
character if the flash TV show didn't
work out they would have just brought
him back on as a guest star on arrow in
future seasons but obviously that went
really well so the show is continuing
let me know though what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what would you like to see them do with
this Rachel ghoul storyline
like how do you think that Oliver is
gonna make it back to Starling without
being the next racial goal there's no
way he can accept the offer I feel like
we're on the same page with that like
there's no way that we're gonna go into
season four with Oliver being head of
the League of Assassins there's gonna
have to be some workaround some crazy
stabby Nyssa workaround
I think what'll end up happening is is
that she'll prove her worth again and
she will become the heir apparent I'll
say just in general the only really big
Easter eggs in the episode where the
creature commandos character came back
in the flashbacks Batman 2:32 daughter
to the demon comic book store line
that's one of the best racial ghouls
stories of all time if you haven't read
it you should read in the comics if you
haven't read it there's a collected
edition called tales of the demon that
has those stories as well as a bunch of
other really cool ones in it I did do a
top five video my top five reach out
ghoul stories a long time ago so I had a
link to that in the description if you
guys want to watch it just in general
though we have to give the arrow writers
and producers a giant high-five for
adapting one of the best Batman stories
of all time I won't say it's the best
but it's definitely one of the most
iconic I think long Halloween or Killing
Joke are probably my favorite Batman
stories of all time right now Dark
Knight Returns is really good too it's
really it's really a shootout for top 5
Batman stories of all time
you could argue all day about it so I
know I still owe you guys a bonus flash
video I haven't quite decided what
that's going to be I'll just I'll find
something fun to do and post that
tomorrow I'll still do a Q&A as well too
so ask all your questions about ratio
ghoul atom craziness it's gonna be a lot
of fun I'm really excited for the next 8
episodes while you guys wait for that
you can click here for my top 5 racial
ghouls stories and you can click here to
learn all about a possible spider-man
post-credit scene in Avengers age of
Ultron thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you